[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja
apple
[Musik]
ich bin sehr stolz dass sie die schweiz
geschafft hat die erlaubten sich so groß
machen dass sich das kleben meditieren
geöffnet hat ist das wünscht und ich bin
stolz dass ich als latino dass ich die
repräsentanten der haupt repräsentant
das macht mich so stolz
[Musik]
große töne aber auch große erfolge
zumindest in der schweiz musiker logo
ist eto'o holt bisher vier mal platin-
und einmal gold anfang jahr gewinnt der
schweizer mit kolumbianischen wurzeln
überraschend einen swiss music award an
selbstvertrauen mangelt es loco s creed
der eigentlich nicolas herzig heißt
nicht siegessicher will er von seinem
geburtsland kolumbien aus ein großer
latin star werden ob er dem
ambitionierten vorhaben gewachsen ist
davon handelt dieses
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier in wetzikon zürich ist nicolas
aufgewachsen
seit drei jahren ist der vater von der
mutter des kindes lebt er getrennt
das sorgerecht für tochter aisha teilen
sich die beiden mehrmals pro woche
besucht er seine mutter isabel herzig
erinnert sich schon als kind wollte
nicolas immer mit dem kopf durch die
wand
[Musik]
so wurde zum beispiel es gibt und gab
und gibt oder das essen unbedingt der
head spin ist unbedingt wurde
das steht auf dem kopf wurde das war
doch immer alles probiert man immer cool
falls ja dann sparen wir verletzt
[Musik]
sport1 hat sie sechs jahre in kolumbien
gelebt in der heimat von nicolas vater
in medellin haben sie tochter johanna
und dann nicolas bekommen kurz nach
seiner geburt sind sie zurück in die
schweiz
durch das begibt das den sohn so eine
sehnsucht hat noch immer noch kolumbien
ein verstoß also sowohl identität und
der hat sich sehen ich keinen
unterschätzen wenn ihr volk auch nicolas
jüngerer bruder ist von kolumbien
fasziniert vor einem jahr wandert diego
aus optisch der schweizer im herzen der
beißer nicolas identifiziert sich mit
den bewohnern medien spicers haben ihren
eigenen slang eigene essens gerichte und
man sagt sie seien von der arbeitsmoral
her kürze der latino hat grundsatz
kommentator berlin pflicht
witzel wenigerath satz ins netz
das ist schon immer so dass man sich
nicht klar was man dahinter meint aber
die eine idee die haben zwar impuls die
pushen
das ist so ja durchaus sinnvoll
mit der einstellung eines messers und
der vision vom weltruhm reist der
zürcher oberländer für einen monat nach
medellin
schon am ersten tag steht ein
kennenlernen mit dem musikunternehmen
sony music kolumbien an
[Musik]
der 29 jährige ist mit seinem team aus
der schweiz angereist das sind sein dj
war für und social media experte in
einem enkel trägers musikproduzent
hendrik anschlag und manager parlament
sie lotto ist hier ein niemand nicolas
muss dem künstlerischen leiter erklären
wer er ist und welche erfolge er in der
schweiz feiern durfte und er zeigt ihm
seine größten hits
[Musik]
sehr gut du machst nichts auf
schweizerdeutsch rein gar nichts
nein das ist nicht mein ding
es ist sehr ungewöhnlich dass einer der
nicht hier aufgewachsen ist diesen klang
so hinbekommt er macht's richtig gut ich
bin etwas überrascht
ich sehe eine große zukunft einen rat
gibt er ihm aber nicolas soll den
schweizer markieren
das sagt der ktm dem stolzen preis hat
er endlich unter seinesgleichen ist wie
so was ist der grund es gibt so viele
artisten du bist aus der schweiz das ist
ein vorteil
du bist der ausländer auf besuch
wieso wir brauchen nicht noch mehr in
der schweiz erzählen wir aber eine
andere geschichte er in der schweiz ja
dort sehen sie dass ich meine herkunft
nicht verleugnen ja behaltet es dort bei
und sie verfolgen was ich hier mache ich
muss etwas aufpassen sonst als es soll
wieso gehst du nicht dort verkaufst du
dich gut aber hier versuchen nicht den
supervisor zu sein
ich sage ganz ehrlich es wird schwierig
werden ich bin ein stolzer kolumbianer
aber ich werde mich zurücknehmen und zum
beispiel auf englisch grüßen es geht
nicht um stolz es ist eine strategie du
nutzt das du von dort kommst es ist wie
im film
jeder spielt eine rolle die nicht real
ist es ist nur eine rolle ist kolumbien
vielleicht doch eine nummer zu groß und
es wird auch immer schwieriger probleme
und eine kolumne spaß habe ich es gar
nicht so heiß aus zur iss machen es ist
dann doch nicht so einfach das dann
umsetzen
aber ich weiß was sie damit meinen es
gab eine zeit da ich mir vergnügen mega
der ökonomischen enders exotischer
gebracht
[Musik]
wenn wohl auch widerwillig nimmt er den
tipp zusammen mit schweizer schoggi mit
auf einen medien marathon auch das
polizei radio heißt die schweizer
willkommen du lebst in der schweiz hat
ein akzent ist fehlerfrei das ist wegen
eines mythos den akzent habe ich nicht
verloren aber viele wörter
[Musik]
seinen sieg eine swiss music awards
macht er gerne zum thema ich bin zur
zeit der beliebteste künstler in der
schweiz
ich bin ein wichtiges aushängeschild ich
bringe den latino sound nach europa ob
die kolumbianer auch an seine träume
glauben bleibt unklar
dieser monat wird bestimmt von
medienterminen und kontakte knüpfen
trotz dichten programm besucht nicolas
seinen vater der wieder hier lebt
brühe jetzt schon sagen
doch meine songs von rio alto
und da war auch da und sind nur so
fließen und so lange vor der mutter weg
danach unterlagen warten bis man wieder
schweigsamen triebwerk sie derzeit ihr
letztes jahr das alles aufbot
jetzt sind wir eigentlich schon
megahertz und muss halt wo darüber die
schon mit der fokus ist das tägliche
brot
mittlerweile kann die callas von der
musik leben
der pensionierte vater wohnt in einem
der besseren viertel zusammen mit seiner
freundin und den beiden
wichtig für diese sollte man schon mal
sieht gebrannt und dann freut man sich
auf den moment und sagt jetzt fehlt
haben wir jetzt das telefon ab
also lieber wieder so weit ist sehr viel
wie bei der liebe materielle gästen
zum video spuckt feuer ich sollte nicht
motor das war es
fernando herzig ist vor rund zehn jahren
in die heimat zurückgekehrt
heute ist mit der ihn sicher geworden
jahrzehntelang aber hielt das
drogenkartell unter blow escobar
die 2,5 millionen metropole im griff das
hat mich sehr eingeprägt
fernando erzählt vom bunten angriff auf
das wohnhaus escobars von einem
raubüberfall dem sie nur knapp entkommen
sind von bildern toter menschen die sich
bis heute in sein gedächtnis gebrannt
haben
nicolas will von der blutigen
vergangenheit nichts wissen
er sieht sich als neue generation von
kaiser's die vorausblickt einfach für
jemanden der behütet aufgewachsen ist
stolz ist er auf das heutige medaillen
die stadt gilt als eine der
innovativsten städte der welt
dazu beigetragen haben neue
transportmittel wie gondeln und
rolltreppen die abgeschiedenen
armenviertel werden somit dem
öffentlichen leben verbunden
zum ersten mal getraut sich nicolas 0
ins berüchtigte banden viertel kommune
adresse
diese rolltreppe lässt das gefährliche
quartier aufleben und lockt touristen an
betreten sollte man die kommune adresse
sicherheitshalber dennoch nur mit einem
guide comcom zur kamera mit wem bist du
hier vom banken tourismus angesteckt
planen nicolas mit seinem bruder und
einem schweizer filmteam den dreh eines
videoclips
armut und bandenkriminalität sie mindern
seine begeisterung nicht als preis hat
träumt er von einem leben in medellin
wenn es aber um die tochter geht ist
nicolas wieder schweizer wollen dann nur
dann wenn es kalt zum sie sich vor nach
b fahren und wenn es dann doch damit
kann man sagen wo man das schweizer
geschätzt dass die risikospiele dass man
vorhabe noch besser laufen und ich so
gemacht und das sind so die
künstlerische freiheit als als schweizer
wo oder wann ich weiß wo problematisch
werden wenn ich mal wieder da lange
[Musik]
die tage dauern meist bis in die nacht
parallel arbeitet der schweizer
musikproduzent mit einer kolumbianischen
produktionsfirma in der gemieteten finca
an neuen songs vom team fordert nicolas
einen unerbittlichen arbeitseifer
[Musik]
vernachlässigt haben so was machen
ich sage das produkt locker wie früher
war mir alles zu viel macht und so
langsam burg ich weiß ich kurz zurück
[Musik]
musik und familie das sind die beiden
pfeiler in die kollegen
[Musik]
zwei monate später zu hause im
zürcherischen krümmt ein durchbruch in
lateinamerika ist noch nicht in sicht
einige radios in kolumbien spiele nun
aber ab und zu seine lieder auch die
kontakte pflegt nicolas weiter der fokus
auf die musik hat sich verstärkt und das
selbstbewusstsein ist ungebrochen
damit der wille da ist herr kollege
moser von der musik transnet am wochende
alles koscher war jeder andere
gleichzeitig nur eine von der
einflussreichste latin erwin künstler in
kolumbien wollte man ihm den
preisausschreiben um seine schweizer
seite betonen aber logos brito ist
keiner der sich gern etwas vorschreiben
lässt daher nichts weiter klar definiert
ist meine erfahrung beim fcb fans
scheitern gehört offenbar nicht ins
konzept von nicolas herzig
kolumbien war sehr viel nervosität in
graz interviews zu sein reicht aber
nicht ein interview marathon spanisch
gibt
als nächste mal wird und es bleibt ein
weiter weg zum welterfolg auf logos
kripo hatte in kolumbien niemand
gewartet
mit seinem eisernen willen wird nicholas
herzig so schnell jedenfalls nicht
aufgeben